[Musique]
en attente des résultats aux états unis
encore ce soir on vous présente un ca
spéciale on a rappelé à la tâche jean
luc landry et jean martin aussant
bonsoir messieurs bonsoir le week-end
commencera plus tard si vous le voulez
bien parce que on a quand même un enjeu
incroyable cette semaine ça se poursuit
il ya 5 et à enjeu avec des écarts de
moins de 2 points de pourcentage dans
quelques états et 0,1 ou 0,2 point de
pourcentage quelques milliers de voix
les réseaux américains donc n'arrive pas
à déclarer la victoire de l'un ou
l'autre
jean martin aussant qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette situation c'est
incertitudes qui perdurent ou à
l'incertitude je la pense assez réduit
tard à mon sens les marchés ont déjà
fait l'hypothèse que la conclusion que
c'est joe biden qui soit président dans
un gouvernement divisé a fait avec un
congrès qui est pas tout à fait bleus et
je pense que si qui est ce qu'on voit
cette semaine avec les hausses ces
fortes qu'on a eu du mal gré qui aura
pas de grand plan de sauvetage à cause
de ce qu'on appelle des grilles de là je
pense que les marchés financiers se
fient davantage à ce que gérons pas à
wadi al hafed que ce que le futur
président pourrait faire sur le plan des
politiques fiscales donc la politique
monétaire semble avoir pris le dessus
sur la politique fiscale pour les
marchés jean-luc vous en pensez quoi
le bas pour venir à geron parole
effectivement il n'y a rien c'est le
discours de politique monétaire
aujourd'hui c'est triplement mort de
cinq mots continue comme avant
alors donc sans éthique que la réserve
fédérale pensent que l'économie est en
ruine
ouais mais qu'est ce que vous pensez de
l'incertitude actuellement qui perdure
mais statistiquement il ya 80%
probabilité probablement le 4 sur 5 de
toute façon il a fait ça fait une grande
chance que mme landry
si vous regardez les marchés
d'aujourd'hui le marché pense aussi n'y
a pas eu de perturbations importantes
n'ont pas remis pour les prévisionnistes
de gagner et on a un chenal de 50 50
à peu près ce qui est le meilleur
scénario pour le marché des affaires et
là ce que vous dites là c'est comme
fondamental c'est comme la base c'est
quoi les couleurs en place où sont les
chiffres vous regardez ça qui vous êtes
c'est ça le
le résultat mais en même temps on a dans
notre homme qui jouait déjà de l'huile
sur le feu qui parle de vote illégaux le
vol d'élection de fraude est ce qu'il
faut craindre quelque chose de sa
détention social et de ses répercussions
jean bertin mais je pense que non en
fait je pense que même son propre parti
de quelques uns de ses collaborateurs
les plus proches ont commencé à
s'éloigner un peu de ses grandes
déclarations et même des réseaux ya qui
ont coupé son point de presse
moi j'ai trouvé ça formidable enfin
enfin on va arrêter de se forcer à
écouter ni bébé tigre
donc je pense qu'il va vite se rendre
compte que tu as isolé puis moi je fais
confiance même mèche mais corner de
dickens a fait plus de deux siècles une
transition pacifique du pouvoir aux
états unis et on va venir une transition
pacifique
je souhaite et je le pense vous le
pensez aussi jean-luc oui même chose
les américains adorent leur constitution
pense que c'est le meilleur le meilleur
document que jamais été écrit et ils
sont prêts à le suivre
alors j'ai pas tout est-ce que c'est
nuisible le jean-luc quand même ce qui
se passe en ce moment la stabilité
économique politique du pays
ça aide pas mais il faut pas surestimer
le gouvernement n'ont pu là l'économie
est très forte le gouvernement
évidemment je peux faire des changements
mais mais ça changera pas le fondement
on s'en va vers un vaccin au premier
temps plus tard et l'économie
fondamentale si vous gardez un petit
commentaire sur le taux de chômage
talât on a eu des larmes dans d'un peu
partout des consignes mais les crimes et
le taux de chômage baisse encore alors
si vous dire que le fondement de reprise
est ce qu'on peut d'accord parce que
j'ai encore des millions d'emplois de
récupérer 2 par rapport au début de
crise
évidemment qu'on augmente à partir de
niveaux très bas il faut pas oublier que
c'est facile d'avoir une hausse quand on
parle de la cave une hausse de 1
quand on parle d'un incessant bourse ans
quand on parle de sens et 1%
donc je pense que l'économie encore
fragile et d'ailleurs je sais c'est
qu'il déclara fait que l'économie a
besoin de tout c'est peut-être là de la
fed sinon tout va s'écrouler parce que
la pandémie était vraiment près du
célèbre l'économie juste si je peux me
permettre des chefs d'al jurf l'antenne
on y ajouter quelque chose on
on est à peu près 3% du sommet de
l'emploi de toute l'histoire des états
unis
est ce la même chose au canada on
comprend alors que le taux de chômage
est plus élevé mais on se connaît on est
partis du plein emploi en fait les états
unis étaient en deçà du taux naturel de
chômage pour l'économie américaine
lorsque la pandémie est arrivé alors son
côté qu' on est on est pas dans les
années 90 où le taux de chômage était de
9 % pour nouvelle audience a baissé d'un
quart de 1% convient de faire baisser
d'encore de 1% malgré une touche comme
problème de coût
on n'est pas dans une récession normale
de toute façon à cesser sinon un autre
type de récession est-ce qu'on peut je
veux poser la question sur lie les
investisseurs parce que investir quelque
part choisir d'investir quelque part se
fait toujours en fonction de critères
bien sûr dans la stabilité politique
est ce que les investisseurs pourraient
faire moins confiance aux états unis
dans le futur
compte tenu de la difficile gestion du
résultat électoral jean bart et le pense
pas non je pense que le président hans
baldung va ramener de la stabilité
peu de crédibilité aussi un peu de calme
et un peu de prestance finalement la
fonction la plus puissante au monde
encore ce jour donc moi je pense que ça
va être plutôt bon pour la confiance
envers les etats-unis et de toute façon
comme on le disait cette semaine le
programme de dubaï n'est pas non plus un
grand programme révolutionnaire qui
change le modèle américain ils savent à
dos mur est demeuré un pays capitaliste
dans lequel les marchés vont encore des
beaucoup de shoots
ouais d'ailleurs on a on a un tableau
lors où on a mis les principales
propositions de durban i done sur ses
investissements verts par exemple 2000
milliards de dollars les hausses
d'impôts
l'élargissement de la couverture
d'assurance public la gratuité partielle
des universités publiques
le made in america pour créer des
emplois non seulement ce n'est pas la
révolution jean-luc mais ce qui va être
capable de faire ça je pense qu'il est
capable de faire plusieurs choses pas du
point de vue des impôts mais tout
dépendra du côté des dépenses
faut pas oublier le coeur le sénat 50 50
les sénateurs sont sûr c'est pas du camp
des sénateurs canadiens qui regardent le
bien public sont des gens qui sont en
affaires ils veulent avoir le même
impôts leur état alors par conséquent
quand vous êtes très très près de 50 50
c'est pas difficile de faire basculer un
ou deux sénateurs de votre côté si vous
voulez faire des dépenses additionnelles
en leur promettant que ça va être très
intéressant pour leur état alors donc
savinois fiscales américaines une
dépense dont les lois pour les dépenses
sont extrêmement complexes
il ya plein de choses sont même pas au
bélier ou au premier but de la dépense
fiscale du sénateur accroche pas quelque
chose justement pour leurs méthodes
donc il ya de bonnes chances de faire
des deals en fait qui est des
négociations qui fasse que d'une puce
une partie de son agenda milliards on se
rendra pas sûr est-ce qui leur demanda
d'aller de l'avant parce que le résultat
est serré quand même jean martin bien
sûr chaque président allait de l'avant
avec sa politique qui gagne par crêpes
whaou par beaucoup en fait c'est comme
ça que le système fonctionne même chez
nous on a des gouvernements qui sont
élus avec 30 quelques pour cent puis il
faut une maison aux un pouvoir absolu en
fait
et pour revenir les mains portable de
dépenses que j'ai avec mentionnait byden
va pouvoir faire des choses sur le plan
environnemental sans avoir l'appui de
ses notes par exemple en passant par la
politique d'achat du gouvernement c'est
le plus grand donneur d'ordres
gouvernement il pourra aussi orienter
des politiques vers les énergies plus
vertes et des entreprises plus verte
donc il ya quand même un bon pouvoir
d'agir dans dans cette plateforme mais
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour qu'ils
t'ont etc servent ou ne dépend pour qui
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour qui ce
ton excellent pour mon père ma première
guitare et les moyens et les vrais pros
pétrole que trois ans puis les moins pro
charbon qui tremble il est beaucoup plus
l'économie verte et d'avenir quant à moi
que deux chambres ont été ces énergies
doit pas trop content aujourd'hui
non ok ça va très loin en effet jean-luc
jean-martin merci d'être sorti de wotan
hier temporairement
on vous laisse tranquille bonne soirée à
la sonde rochette à mardi